hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today matching the
questions from one of our YouTube
viewers sparkly mango 13 who wrote
insane hey I absolutely love your videos
I'm thinking about getting into
marketing in the future I'm in the tenth
grade and it was wondering if you could
make a video about getting an internship
there's a marketing firm near the city I
live in and I have no no idea about how
to even begin to get involved thank you
so thanks for the question you know
welcome from with the 10th grade it's
awesome great to hear from you in terms
of creating an internship I don't know
how big this company is but smaller
companies always need help the biggest
challenge with bringing on interns
typically is the internship period is
really short often and there's too much
pen holding and training that's involved
and too little value that comes back on
the intern side and this is the child
that you're gonna have so if they have a
regular internship program you might
qualify for it it may be a little young
because if they're looking at interns
they're typically looking at university
interns or not high school interns but
it's still possible the the thing you're
gonna have to get over is making
yourself stand out and so step one is
showing your ambition right if you can
show that you're really eager you're
really ambitious you really want to help
then that's gonna cut you know you out
from everybody else who may be trying to
apply to them and a couple ways to do it
one get involved in any of their
campaigns so look at their social media
channels that their marketing firm you
have to be in social media look at their
youtube look at their Twitter look at
their Facebook LinkedIn wherever they
are and start to get involved comment on
their projects offer suggestions give
praise where you think you really like
something just try to get involved so
that they know who you are and if you
are repeatedly commenting on something
then you'll start to stand up they'll
start to know you the next step I would
do is try to identify who the leadership
is at the organization and again the
smaller the company the easier it is to
find out and get in touch with somebody
and try to just set up a time to go and
talk to them people like helping people
who seem motivated and ambitious and
they think
gonna take their advice so as an example
I get asked a lot from local
entrepreneurs and from entrepreneurs on
the web to mentor them and to answer
question for them a lot of times they
just do it through these YouTube videos
the people who are closer in my city of
Toronto I'll often meet up with them but
only the ones who seem really genuine
and who I think are really gonna take my
advice and there's a great feeling of
joy when you feel like you're helping
somebody out and that they're taking
your advice and they're gonna use that
and and there's there's a huge benefit
to mentors as well as mentees in that
mentorship relationship the biggest fear
and the biggest frustration is that
they're not going to do anything with
your advice you're going to waste your
time and then that feels that feels
terrible feels like you just wasted an
hour of whoever long you spent with that
person and so the challenge that you
have is standing out and showing them in
advance and you're the kind of person
who is gonna really listen to advice and
take it and be helpful and not just the
person's gonna waste their time and so
one method that I've used there that
that's been used on me that I found
really helpful was a woman wrote in
saying she's basically just starting up
and she wanted to meet me
to ask my advice on her business and one
of the lines that she used in her email
was something along the lines of even if
it's just walking with you while you're
on your way to a meeting I'll bring the
coffee and treats and I'd be happy to
meet with you for that for that short
walk to your car something like that and
that really showed me that hey this
person is really ambitious she's really
serious she really wants to learn and so
I took the meeting and so even showing
things like that so if you get first
involved in in all their social media
channels and give some advice and and
just praise some of the things that
they're doing or give some tips that you
think might be helpful or some other
resources and then try to line up a
meeting with hopefully the founder of
the business if it's a small company if
not somebody you know lower down if it's
a bigger company and show that you're
eager to learn you have a few questions
don't don't I wouldn't leave in with I'm
looking for an internship opportunity
because if they don't have anything or
they see your 10th grade you may have a
lot of strikes going against you they're
just go and ask for a meeting say you're
a marketing student
you're really wanting to learn about the
business you're really eager and excited
you've been following all the great work
that you're doing on social media
channels and you'd really appreciate you
know 20 30 minutes at their time to grab
a cup of coffee or even if it's on the
way to a meeting that you could walk
with them to you'll bring treats in the
coffee and that hopefully will give you
the ability to meet them in person learn
about their business see if it's
something that you're still excited
about and and then start looking for
opportunities and operators will come
from the conversation show you're eager
come prepared with questions that you
want to ask them things that you're
genuinely interested in learning about
you know from marketing that you want to
learn from them and then see ongoing if
there's gonna be some kind of fit but
the first key is getting in the door
learning from them and when you do get
that meeting you know make sure you're
on time you look good you're
professional you've shown up with coffee
or with with some treats and make that
first good impression so that you're
ready to go and rock and roll when that
when you had that meeting so hopefully
that helps good luck keep me posted with
your progress I'd love to hear how
things work out for those of you
watching if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up below what makes
gonna do more for you and if you have a
comment about your own business or a
question feel free to leave it in the
comment section below I always read
those and I respond everybody who writes
in so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you